I'm sorry I'm sorry hi welcome to this
video my voice is failing me playing
yeah one of those guys that I cannot
pronounce and yeah I wanted to avoid
them and typical on Ben Oni that we
usually get the snake benoni of course a
snake benoni is a good opening for white
but just want to have something
different here let's see what is coming
up with do you three year yeah might
lead to Kings Indian attack type of
position is going t six I really have
forgotten how this life is how this is
played this is some eve form was that
night a 4mm I love cod shop let's see
Knight a5 as a annoying move our okay so
but isn't there should be three c5 be
four so a slight issue that seemed
before nice position it's somewhat
underdeveloped it doesn't really have a
great activity voice pieces yeah hmm so
do i go e5 yeah let's not clear even d
for the move d4 Knight takes then g5
it's a very dynamic way of trying to go
about it I can also take hmm teak
between a 427 queen bee three it's
something like that it's not bad hmm 5v5
I don't know that that feels a bit
strange yeah I wonder do I take this or
not I think I'm taking but I'm not not
totally convinced if that is the right
way to play Queen D 7 i'm going back to
be three happy that i have provoked
queen 37
Queen B 6 is a possible move but also 95
with tempo gains yeah let's do it let's
go for that so what now and support this
night I've got two nice looking nights
on c4 85 and his bishops are not doing
that much even though this is certainly
nothing yeah extraordinarily grateful
white but I'm quite happy with my
position if he moves i have a drogue
there might be nigh def seven things
okay what is he doing there rupee seven
maybe
it's not a very comfortable position for
black to play you're somewhat passive I
don't have any key ideas what to do okay
so i can take play night mmm interesting
i can do this it's a very noise check on
deform mmm Knight takes Queen takes as
always check on d4
mmm that's it's an annoying little thing
and I don't see a clear play play here
let's do this going for ruby three and
then doubling their it's not a very not
great
yeah I only only recognize this
possibility now okay it's not it's not
the end of the world try to try to say
that my night is better than his bishop
which is pretty easy statement to make
no it's not much fun for black this
position okay so here allows this and
now probably will be one
now dark when you form it's not doing
that so let's activate got the open file
and decent control this Bishop stays so
bad somehow so maybe a queen a4 might be
something might be something would
really like to trade Queens him and my
king is somewhat uncomfortable oh I will
look Jenny one check yeah that's a way
to lose the game blunder stuff time when
a completely commanding position where
black had nothing that he can do I shoot
that's very unnecessary black was just
in a very bad passive position I mean
very bad is wrong but he had no way of
winning the game ever if I don't blunder
stuff which I did ah awful really awful
now his position was bad because he has
a the bishop one evade is just terrible
now
now you still playing without the bishop
but it doesn't matter it's two pawns so
very easy age for simple moves to win
yeah yeah always he had to give away
easy points like that white resigns yeah
and then like it's just worse in this
position and yeah it's just worse then I
just have to be more precise if I get
Queens off for example that that's going
to be a very one-sided end game the
black suffers for a long time and
somehow I didn't manage to do that this
looks right yeah some way i wrote you
have to have to play better maybe quincy
three or something what did i do Queenie
to g6 but this was good i have got
control that the only thing that didn't
I my available to overlook that simpler
Queen d1 check which was just a terrible
terrible way of playing maybe it's
active enough thats it's possible maybe
it's his active enough then i don't i'm
not able to force the Queen trade and
without the Queen traded will be
difficult because my king is so open so
this well kind of whom yeah and now I
just have to avoid avoid this is pet so
it's just a Charl move yeah
hmm basically doesn't matter justjust
anymore I mean black is in a situation
where you can never do anything because
he's playing without the PCM but it's
not easy for white to make some progress
if he goes Rudi form yeah I maybe have
to do this all right it's hard to
imagine wide winning this mean it's it's
it's very unattractive for black bus
because of the bad bishop but probably I
cannot win Nucky i can bring the king up
here Quincy to now I just need to trade
Queens then everything is good yeah I
can start to play against those pawns
against f7 and so on that position would
be really okay but it's not so easy to
get but this just like Joe just handing
in the game for ya their fur just to
give it okay thanks for watching